in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Joe and
Jessica are with us hey guys how are you
doing great welcome where you guys from
st. Joseph Michigan about half hour
north of South Bend oh wow very cool
welcome to Nashville it's good to have
you and so you're here to do the
debt-free scream that's right I love it
how much have you paid off two hundred
and sixty thousand dollars over twelve
years we paid the last ninety eight
thousand off in about 40 months
Wow that must be house and everything
that's everything yep very cool how old
are you two she's 34 I'm 33 I'm three
months yeah by about four months yeah so
just a little bit of the year I'm older
than Sharon's older than me every year
which is all right now it's awesome very
good she's [ __ ] so I'm gonna be in
serious stuff when I get home but I
anyway so but you're 30-something years
old every 3334 your house is paid for
what's this house worth Oh about 225 I
would say you guys are weird
yeah Barry you are so weird before we
paid off but that we are weird but now
we're really now we're really weird no
question so during the 12 years what was
the range of your income between sixty
and ninety five thousand right so did
you work the baby steps where you
knocked out the other debt first and
then got your stuff going and emergency
fund and then came back and did the
house yeah we only had two dots we had
52,000 and undergrad when we got married
12 years ago so we worked on that and
also the you know the house was right
after so it's 52 and student loans and
the 208 so when you got married you
started this journey what what caused
you to decide you could get out of debt
and believe this was gonna happen tell
me your story
we just we knew we could do it I guess
overall the main thing is a lot of
people want to get out of debt and what
I wanted to share with you was that you
have to decide to get out of debt
because you can want to do a lot of
things but if you never decide to do it
and if you never take action on it and
action and action and action on it so
that was I mean we read your books I
know your book
Dave I wanted to share three with you
real quick the power of habit by Charles
Duhigg that was on yep that was on on
trade leadership phenomenal habits and
II Stanley's asked it yep
and the job Mannion satisfied so what's
the last one
and Jeff Mannion satisfied I haven't
read that one yeah so the guy's worse
that Andy Stanley book pretty sure I did
awesome endorsed upon ideas but yeah
he's a good friend but yeah also very
cool but he's desktops one at a time
obviously you've got the baby stuff so
but I mean you got married your early
20s at this stage real early 20s how did
you know to do all of this well I mean
cuz that's that's weird y'all I mean
most people just go spend their 20s
being broke right we're both nerds it's
definitely a bigger nerd than I am you
know we were just on board and let's do
this so you plugged into our stuff at
what point in the journey shortly after
the one of my bosses and during college
we met with them and he said well you
know how much money do you have on the
bank and I said seventeen and he thought
seventeen hundred so he about had a
heart attack so he ran into his house
and came out with two yearbooks and said
have you considered delivering pizzas
you should probably read these right now
and I got nervous and I was like no
we've got seventeen thousand and he's
like whoa what do you mean seven so you
know we started you know it was a lot of
work during calm I mean we have the
student loan debt yeah also I was just I
think it's part of us we're both out the
fifty thousand of student loan debt then
you go on to baby step three to the
emergency fund yeah then you start
paying on the house and doing retirement
yep so how long and so that paying off
the house then took how long we got the
mortgage than June of 2007 so seven
years yeah six years and in that whole
time in that whole time we both got our
masters that were paid for so we didn't
have to take on a graduate loans or
anything and then also had two little
boys too all paid off your house in
eight years yeah yeah I know
so what are your master's in educational
leadership
MBA with focus on finance of course he's
a nerd yes I guess but you guys this is
incredible I mean I know you've been
working at this really really hard and
you can really focus in your nerds I
get all of that I don't know I can't I
can't tell by talking to you I don't
think you realize how unusual this
really is you really are weird
you really are this is amazing
you're gonna be so wealthy it's gonna be
unbelievable I mean you got complete
education everything's paid for you're
done you're 33 34 years old unbelievable
man I mean the numbers you know what
you've seen them man they just go nuts
from here the things you're gonna be
able to do the things you know matter
money you're gonna be able to give to
help others I mean it's it's amazing yo
I asked if we could go on a trip to
Disney World though don't tell the boys
a surprise yeah I hope not
so you're holding a map yeah your hands
the United States of America so being
the nerd that I am in the spreadsheet
guy I would go over the budget and the
she would just gloss over I'm like this
isn't gonna work I need to have
something she always talks about being a
visual learner so we had 50 months or 50
payments left so I still have all their
50 states so and this was short shortly
after Chris Hogan when I saw him do that
give permission to hate that and for me
I didn't we didn't like that we didn't
we weren't gonna go back into debt and
we were paying off the house but now
with that intensity so anyway
got the map and I said all right after
each payment that we make you can color
in a state and so it should have taken
five different colors but there's only
you know three on the map and we color
it in Alaska so we went smallest which I
wouldn't recommend starting with Rhode
Island because it wasn't very motivating
for her just to color and nothing
against the citizens of Rhode Island so
anyway each time we'd make an extra
payment that's why there's a lot of blue
on the map and then you know we finished
with red so oh so that so each so 2013
was orange then the next was not a
prediction of the election or yeah no
way that was coincidental anuradha very
very cool
well congratulations so do you already
have Chris Hogan's return smartbook no
not yeah will you do now that's your
next step is to retire inspired now now
that you've gotten out of that house and
everything oh my goodness yeah and we'll
give you a sign to copy a Christmas book
and get you guys started I'm so proud of
y'all way to go you aren't you're rock
stars man you're heroes very very well
done all right Joe and Jessica Saint
Joseph Michigan two hundred and sixty
thousand dollars paid off that's their
house and everything in twelve years
making sixty to ninety five a year count
it down
let's hear a debt free scream three can
you imagine what it would be like no car
payment no student loan that's been
around so long you think it's a bad no
master card haven't discovered bondage
or American distress can you imagine
what it would be like to have no
payments no house payment proverbs 22:7
says the borrower is slave to the lender
you know when you'll know that's true
when you're free that's when you'll know
that's when you'll know and you know
what joe said it is genius you have to
decide and then he took Chris Hogan's
hate bet mantra not just merely dislike
that not be intellectually opposed to
death I freakin hate it because it taken
my income it's taking my family's dreams
it's taking my ability to be
outrageously generous at a whim not
anymore
how would you like to be 33 and 34 years
old have a several hundred thousand
dollar home paid for well you can
decide the quote Joe decide today's your
day yeah I'm talking to you
yeah you you think this is about
somebody else this is about you today's
your day go home and tell your spouse I
decided we're freaking changing this
deal I'm sick and tired of working my
butt off and have nothing to show for it
except some smiling banker at the other
end of the phone stop it
it's stupid decide to be free man these
guys are inspiring what a cool couple
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show and so
you have to break the cycle you have to
flip this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you